i loved your work in rogue one
and i think that even though star wars
fans are
more divided than democrats and
republicans in terms of
you know with star wars rogue one is a
really good movie
and it is it's really good um
and i i think your work in it is like
fantastic
um that is one of those films where
there was a lot of stuff behind the
scenes in terms of the
doing reshoots in terms of everything
that went on with making that movie
when you look back on it do you remember
it fondly
do you remember it as like a challenge
like what what's your memory on it
i i definitely look back on it fondly i
it was a challenge
in that the script was changing at a
certain point
um it's almost like the way that disney
like that they were
you know we're frozen too you're talking
about how they uh didn't have act three
a year out
you know that we there was a a certain
point early on where
the story shifted there was a new writer
was brought in and things were changed
and so
i had met uh jen
erso's character one way
um and then they even used it in the
trailers and p
where i say i'm your um hello
um cassian said
you are my a friend i will not kill you
and
people would when i would go to cons at
comic-cons they'd say could you write
that on my pen like it's not in the
movie that quote it's
it was just an early version of how i
mentioned erso
so things change so we were on set and
it would be like okay so this scene is
after we've met her before oh we had we
just met in a new scene that happened so
there was
that's tough that's tricky that
that can shake your faith um
but in working with gareth uh edwards i
love working with him
uh and um
diego luna is a lot of fun that there's
there were a lot of pictures on set like
from on-set pictures that i got to see
and there's a lot of
of me and diego and i'm laughing i'm
just laughing my ass off a lot so
and we went to malt to maldives
the maldives i think or it's my i used
to know how to say it
um and we went to jordan so we were
flying all these places before they had
built the thing that they built for
mandalorian where
you go to long beach and you can be
anywhere you're surrounded by all those
screens we were actually flying to
places and doing the whole
filmmaking thing and waking up at
whatever time in the morning to hook up
with some bedouins so they could take us
to this one
place that we could overlook to see
jeddah
man so seeing stormtroopers on actual
camels and they're like
they're gonna fix the camels later that
stuff was magic man
magic i really like rogue one a lot and
considering how much it went through
in terms of the story changes with
reshoots with everything else
it doesn't make sense how good it is
it's it it's yeah i'm being completely
serious but i also think that that
ending with vader in the hallway
it carries a lot of weight i agree
that's badass
and and yeah and you know that
tony gilroy coming in at the end and
doing all the rewrites that that
like i feel like this this is this is
what
tony did like here we had a movie and
tony went great okay here
remove this sew this together and put
this in this there we go it's like it
was like that's kind of what it did
like he took it and went oh yeah then
move this over here and there we go
um it was still the same thing it just
connected things a little bit tighter um
but gareth man k2so would not be k2so
the k2 that ended up in the movie
without gareth and without the decisions
that gareth made like all of the stuff
of
like lines that i said were just i was
goofing around half the time
because gareth made it so much fun on
set that uh
it was so easy going in so pro actor
such a pro actor director
uh that things that like
um um we get caught i'm i'm trying i'm
pretending that cassie was a prisoner
and saying um
uh like hit him silence
uh and there's a fresh one if you mouth
off again like
that stuff would not have made it that
was just goofing around and that was
that was gareth that he he let us goof
around that that ended up that that
ended up becoming
a tone of the character throughout the
movie and ended up in the movie finally
tony gilroy is what we call talented and
um
you know there's probably a reason why
he was brought on for that indoor series
uh because he's uh you know talented
writer um
i i don't know um are you doing and or
are you a part of this i will be one day
they're shooting it right now i'm not in
it
but if it stays on the air and
[Music]
story keeps getting told i'll end up in
there
you know it's a shame i i love
you know i i you know i went to
i'm in all these announcements like for
the show
and uh you know it's it's
it's i had suggested at d23 when we
announced the show
that it'd be called k2 fast
k2 furious the cassian andor series
and um that's not happening uh it's
called andor
and you know i think
i don't know i don't know i don't know
i'll end up in it at a certain point
i do know this i have to be on stilts
for it
i have to be because the character's
seven one and i
i i'm not one of those guys who's like
somebody else can do my motion capture
and i'll
voice it later or any of that kind of
stuff i'll have to do the motion capture
so
i turn 50 in march i hope they get to it
soon because i'm not going to be on
stilts in like
five years i'm not doing it i'm not
doing stilts well it depends
disney has this thing called dump trucks
of money so you really never know
tell me more of this dump trucks
[Laughter]
so you're not in it now but the plan
would be if it continues on the air then
you would do it i'm going to be
in the show it's just the story that uh
tony is telling
doesn't involve k2so until later on
does that mean in the first season or so
you're saying if it goes to a second
i can't be too specific i can def i can
never say i'm not going to be in the
first season